I love you know especially when you're
inspiring and girls and they're looking
up to you and they get so excited about
these hearts that we're playing I mean
it's like the best thing ever and Emily
VanCamp is in fine fighting form in
Captain America Civil War
people are liking that little those
little head kicks I know and it was
really cool to do it Scarlett because
I've loved her in all of the previous
movies Scarlett Johansson is just one of
many Hollywood heavyweights emily is
starring alongside in the film there's
Robert Downey jr. Chris Evans and Paul
Rudd just to name a few
wow this is awesome it's still quite
nerve-wracking there's a lot of moments
where you just sort of trying to process
it all you know but it's so much fun and
you know having done the Winter Soldier
there's a there's a level of comfort
there before landing in the Marvel
Universe she starred as the duplicitous
femme fatale emily Thorne on revenge for
four seasons I'm fighting to win you
back Emily met her real-life beau Josh
Bowman on the series and not too long
ago she tweeted about his new TV pilot
so maybe we'll see an on-screen reunion
too I'm biased but I think he's said
he's amazing and hopefully it goes we'll
see for now she's thrilled to be back as
agent Sharon Carter someone else me like
who would win in a fight between them
and I had to say emily Thorne
Sharon's very technical and you know
she's an agent but you know without
emily Thorne she's got some got some
issues